[Música]
en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología
soy valentina torre sánchez y es un
gusto acompañarlos iniciamos este
programa en reino unido pese a que el 5
g apenas está empezando a usarse en una
parte del mundo y que falta tiempo para
que exista en otros lugares un grupo de
científicos británicos ya se está
enfocando en el 6 y en lo que definen
como teletransportación virtual
con el 5 g podemos transmitir realidad
virtual tridimensional de 360 grados de
cualquier objeto o persona
pero lo que no se puede hacer es lograr
una interacción tu interés
pero es posible en lo que llamamos 6g
olvidó a una sincronización de alguien
de alta precisión y con sexo
y esta es la primera demostración de dos
personas de realidad virtual que se dan
ammann versión real este tipo explica
kings hans los investigadores pertenecen
al instituto de sistemas de comunicación
y exponen que desde el 1 hasta el 5 g
sólo la vista y el oído se han podido
transmitir pero con esta opción también
entrarían a jugar el gusto del olfato y
el tacto efecto efectivamente cuando
transmitimos todos los sentidos humanos
en conjunto con la realidad virtual ver
los vídeos de 360 grados
tridimensionales de una persona y
proveemos interactividad con objetos
estamos activando la teletransportación
virtual enabled por el equipo señala que
esta tecnología tendría múltiples usos
un médico podría asistir virtualmente
hasta la vivienda de una persona y
sentir su temperatura o tomar su pulso
además resaltan que sería muy útil si en
algún momento las personas deben
distanciarse físicamente y soy un fan de
mi hija dijo que en la pandemia hemos
tenido problemas para visitar a nuestros
seres queridos a nuestros padres desde
hace más de 18 meses
con esta teletransportación virtual
haríamos la vida mucho más sencilla y
natural
remotamente podemos interactuar y ver a
nuestros seres queridos interactuar con
nuestra familia o nuestros amigos sin
importar dónde se encuentren
pasamos ahora a hablar de temas
espaciales hace pocos días estábamos
celebrando el regreso de inspiration for
la primera misión enteramente civil que
fue al espacio estuvo tres días
orbitando la tierra y los integrantes
regresaron a salvo constituyó un hito
para el turismo espacial recordemos que
la misión fue lanzada en un cohete
privado y en una cápsula privada ambos
y ninguno de los tripulantes tenía
entrenamiento profesional como piloto
además no hubo ningún tipo de
supervisión de la nasa o de la agencia
espacial europea pues ahora otra
particular misión saldrá de la tierra es
rusa ha sido denominada proyecto
challenge' y está previsto que parta el
5 de octubre su particularidad es su
objetivo van a grabar una película
durante 12 días en la estación espacial
internacional un programa mixto que
estuvimos entrenando juntos por mes y
medio antes los chicos estuvieron
estudiando las bases teóricas de
supervivencia solar con gravedad pero en
otras palabras se acercaron todo lo
posible a lo que será el vuelo espacial
los cursos luego por mes y medio tuvimos
un gran número de entrenamientos en la
estación y una nave espacial
el tiempo total del entrenamiento fue de
tres meses para el director y la actriz
que fueron seleccionados entre miles de
aspirantes la trama será de una médica
que tiene que ser enviada al espacio
para practicarle una cirugía a un
astronauta
a pesar de todas las dificultades
durante este camino difícil esto es muy
interesante y es una gran satisfacción
incluso pensar que realmente podría
suceder es hermoso cambiamos de tema y
vamos a la ciudad francesa de
estrasburgo para conocer un
supercomputador que servirá para tratar
a pacientes con más precisión se
encuentra en el hospital de la
universidad de pie
usa inteligencia artificial y asiste al
personal sanitario durante las cirugías
para prevenir mejor y manejar los
riesgos asociados a una presión
sanguínea baja lo que puede hacer que
los órganos del cuerpo no estén lo
suficientemente oxigenados pese a que
para muchas personas la idea de ver un
robot puede ser interesante para otras
puede generar temor esto es lo que dicen
los expertos
queremos que la gente crea que los
robots reemplazarán a los médicos y
manejarán automáticamente la salud para
nosotros es solo más información es un
supercomputador que nos da alarmas la
información
el aparato ha sido implementado en
instituciones de europa y eeuu y conecta
al paciente mediante un catéter central
es así como la máquina analiza en tiempo
real las variaciones de la presión
arterial y las compara con una base de
datos de miles de personas
la pantalla nos dice si hay una cifra
alta si hay una probabilidad de
hipotensión buena nos dice si no hacemos
nada y seguimos en esa situación la
presión arterial caerá por debajo de lo
que queremos y ese es el momento quizás
de qué decides o si el paciente necesita
una intervención a que esto sea un hacha
mostró llegamos hacia el final de este
espacio a ustedes gracias por
acompañarme y recuerden que pueden
repetir este y otros programas en
nuestra web france24 puntocom
[Música]